Have you, uh, very bright particles or fragments or something that's, uh, go fifty-five
is it over?
No, I don't understand.
There's a whole bunch of big ones on my website.
It's just bright.
Looks like the more that you lie, I'd run with them.
Yeah, nice.
Some of them are shaped, they're very, uh, jagged, angular, uh, fragments or something.
That's, it looks like fluid or something.
Not to me, it looks like pieces of something, uh.
Roger.
Very bright.
Exactly like I'm in Charlie.
Yeah.
Five for the most part, uh, these fragments are not, uh, are coming at a very slow rate.
I've tried a couple figures of them, uh, different settings.
Uh, you may get an idea of what, uh, at least the patterns look like.
Roger, I gotcha.
We're all ears on these fragments.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Here, what they might be.
Well, you know, I, I don't know, a number of possibilities.
Uh, if you had some kind of, uh, I got the impression maybe they would curse a little bit
as if they might be, uh, off the side of the S4B, uh, it's a wild guess.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yes.
Uh, as such.
I had to go possibly, uh, maybe there'sck coming off of it.
Right.
I noticed on one piece of, uh, the elevator last week, uh, one of the flags, I thought it was
an S2 and it might be an S4, looked like with steeling.
Maybe that's what you got.
And the S4B, Ph.
Ph.
very slight tumbly with a diffraction.
Roger, come at that.
Every once in a while, a fragment of considerably higher velocity than the other goes across my window.
But that's very rare.
Right there.
Okay, that's a few of you, I saw, I wasn't back.
You see?
Yeah.
Okay.
My bad.
At least there's no apparent relative motion between fright.
I didn't want.
I'll take two pictures about a minute apart if I can.
And it'll be frame 70.
Okay, frame 70.
And my impression is that they are flat, flake-like, vertical, some maybe six inches across.
And although there's no relative motion between it two, most of them seem to be twinkling.
And I think for the most part they're all moving away from us.